So we look at the evolution of the routing table of this source using this coral
approach to key-based routing. Where in every step,
we are going the half distance toward the desired
destination. Now reducing the distance by exactly half,
may not always be possible because I may
not have a way to reach that particular
node. So it is approximately we reducing the distance
by half, so let's run through this example
to illustrate, how the there key based routers works?
So the XOR distance between the source and the
destination is is 10, so target for my first
half is going to be,to a node that is
five distant from the desired destination. The node that
is five distant from the desired destination is node
number one because the XOR of one and four
is five. So this is my target that
is half the distance to my desired destination.
But unfortunately I don't have a direct way.
Of reaching one because I don't have that entry
in my routing table and therefore, I'm going
to go to a node that is approximately half
the distance and I could have gone to
either two or zero, close to the desired half
the distance metric, but to make forward progress
towards the desired destination, I'll go to this
guy who is Four distant from the desired
destination. So I make a iiiicall to this node
because I can not reach him. I go to him, and I'm going to ask him.
Hey I am looking for someone who is
two distant from my desired destination which is four.
And when I send my request over to him He responds to me and says, look I have
information on three nodes that are not exactly too distant but close enough,
four, five and seven are the nodes that I have. Who are close enough to the
two distant neighbor that you're looking for. The
two distant neighbor is this guy. But even
this node that I'm reaching that is four
distant from my desired destination, he doesn't know
anyone that is two distant from the destination,
and so he is going to respond to
me and say. I don't have exactly what
you're looking for, but I have information about
nodes four, five, and seven that are close
enough to who you're looking for. That's the information
that I get back. So when i get the response from this node, what I'm getting
back is information on how to reach nodes
number four, five, and seven. So I'm now going
to populate my routing table to evolve it to this new state where it shows that
in addition to what I started with originally,
I have now new information about how to reach
node number four Node number five, which I
already had, and node number seven, which is
the new information I got. So you can see that from this, I evolved to this
by adding two more reachable entries in my routing table, namely nodes four and
seven. So what do I want to do next? Well, the next thing that I want to do is,
I want to go to someone who's too distant
from the desired destination because I reduced the distance
by half, and now I want to reduce it even
further by half. That means I want to get
to a node that is too distant from
the desired destination, that is this guy right here.
But I don't have a way of reaching him. So I'm going to go to a node that is
close enough to the desired target. The target is
too distant from. The desired destination. I don't have
an entry for him. I could either go to
the guy that is three distant from the desired destinatnion,
or that is one distant from the desired destination.
Obiviously I want to go closer to the destination so I'm
going to go to this guy. Normally if I went
to the guy who is Too distant from the destination
I would have asked him for. I'm looking for
someone who is one distant from the desired destination, but
in this case, it turns out that I've already
reached the guy that is one distant, because I did
not have an entry for the guy who is
two distant from the desired destination. So this guy is
going to get my request that says I'm looking for
somebody who is one distant from the desired destination and
he looks at his [UNKNOWN] table and says,
these are the nodes that I know, satisfy the
criteria that you're looking for, 4, ,5, and 7.
That's what I get back. I know that one
thing is happening here, and that is - After
my first hop, I got back node IDs for
four, five, and seven, which are the response for
my requests saying I'm looking for somebody who's too
distant from the desired destination. Because it
gave approximately the nodes that are having
the characteristic of being too distant from
the desired destination, including. The node number
four itself. So my table evolved at this step with a direct way
of reaching node number four as well. But notice that I'm not being greedy here.
Because in the second step, I want to reduce
my distance only by half from the first step, and
that is. I want to go to somebody who's too
distant from the design destination. That's what I did. And
I got back this response. And when I get
back the response, I'm going to populate my table again. But
in turns out, I did not get any new information
at this step because I only have the information about
four, five and seven. At the end of my first RPC call as well. Now I have
a way of reading the [INAUDIBLE] and in my
conscious I can feel good that I'm not being
greedy I can now the target is zero and now I can make the call directly To the
desired destination and get back the response that I
want. So you can see that in this coral's
key-based routing, using this idea of reducing
my distance to my desired destination by half
at every harp. What it results in is the fact that the latency that I am
going to experience in order to reach
my desired destination is increased, because I have
to take more number of hops in order to get to the desired destination. Even if
I have a direct way of reaching my desired destination, I am not doing that.
I am actually reducing my distance by half every time. In order to get to my
desired destination and the reason is I'm
placing common good more important than my own
latency. I'm avoiding the tree saturation that can
occur at the destination if everybody is greedy.
That comes at the cost of increased latency But
that's okay. What we are shooting for is common good.